all right boys what challenges did you
have at amiami so for army army we have
three challenges
because uh we yeah we just want to make
it a little spicy yeah yeah we thought
that we could spend a lot of money there
yeah and and we did we uh this was
probably gonna be the longest segment
yet because we bought a lot of figures
so my one were fairly varied my one was
get a figure that's american uh buy a
wall scroll and buy an incestuous series
and shout i love incest while holding it
now for the incestuous one i'm gonna
have to finish that
here because i didn't have enough time
to actually grab it and shout it because
literally the moment i picked it up
sounds really convenient to me the
literally the moment i picked it up the
staff came over and just took it out
he's like this one okay took it out of
my hands i was like
i can't even tell him i like incest yeah
that's how damn i was like wait no i
have to say i like you that's just like
stage hazards you know it's not it's not
it's no one's fault but you should have
done it i'll be happy to take half a
point for this honestly because
i'd be
i'd like to at least get half of one
because i did buy i did finish half the
challenge i did actually buy an
incestuous figure i just literally
didn't have the time to get you know say
the thing so if we're nice to you you're
saying you'll be nice to us at some
point i have to be nice to you guys what
do you mean
all right i got his back all right i
guess i can't have half the point i got
his back what's the figure then the
figure
as long as he shouts out
shouted out on the podcast so i can
judge what the [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
that i shout out era manga sensei just
forgot
everybody round of applause
hold on joey well done i'm proud of you
i'm proud of you joey we got a prison
this is the only one i was like there
has to be an orimo figure yeah please
let there be an orient this the first
time i ever in my life prayed for an
orie mo figure yeah couldn't find it so
i was like [ __ ] what else what else is
incest what else is incest i know i'll
ask the incest man right here so i ran
up to god i said bro
if you scratch my back i'll scratch
yours
what's an incest shot
and i and i just gave him some
philosophical [ __ ] that i made up on
the spot yeah even though i've i saw
about 10 erimanga sensei figures along
the way why is there so many
i don't know i don't know i don't know
it's popular enough i guess but uh it's
okay okay
i guess replace this lemon star with
that yeah yeah but yeah there you go i
found myself a sakiri figure
uh it's actually not too bad to be
honest with you i'm not exactly a fan of
uh arimanga sensei but this is actually
pretty solid i think you'd have the fbi
knocking if you said you were well i
mean gone should be used to that by now
right
uh this one was uh 211 dollars
211 dollars for an air market
yeah this i mean i don't know where i
didn't have like your eagle like incest
eagle vision so uh this is the only one
i could find
i'm okay not seeing the figure you know
i'm sure there's like a child's play mat
there what the [ __ ] is that yeah i'll
bring it out but i'll bring it out don't
worry
i think it's supposed to symbolize
sagiri's like bed right what happens in
this anime why is it children's style uh
because she is a hentai artist
she's uh yeah yeah the her she's like
she's the error manga she's the aramonga
yeah and
and the brother i believe is an error
manga an author right
he's like yes he is an author how do i
remember more of her
i don't know man
bro she's practically got like the
[ __ ] cars bed bro what is that she's
not she's not a hen basically this
figure um this series is like the series
from hell you know this is this is the
series it truly is oh no what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
all right and what the [ __ ]
i mean how old is saggier again in the
show i have no idea uh you do not want
to know yeah probably not probably
probably not legal
probably we're not gonna be allowed to
say that yeah probably not allowed to
say it there's some kind of like
liability on alpha bro
there you go there's sagiri
i think this goes where does this go
basically the series like should burn in
hell uh
and that's why i memed it up so much
yeah why what didn't you i i remember a
certain gig making a video called i love
this dumpster truck or something like
that
i think it's literally called error
market sensei is a master it's a
masterpiece
there you go there's the masterpiece
right there i love incest
hey i completed the challenge yeah
you're proud of me i'm proud i'm
probably proud of you take one of the
figures away right you've completed uh
you've completed your character arc now
i did it guys you proud of me mom
[Laughter]
i'll keep this here because i still have
to set it up but what were your guys's
challenge i mean i guess i'll take out
my first challenge
well why don't we towels the challenges
first guys we have some reason to
understand you know the first challenge
yeah so obviously you guys know my first
challenge
because we told you to buy it because
you guys told me to buy it and uh
i'm i'm gonna be honest with you
i uh i'm not exactly unhappy with it
honestly because because you guys were
gonna get what were you guys gonna make
me buy again ram ram
okay you you you were gonna make me buy
ram or mama
not mamaco if there was one other
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
i can read the last line of kanji isn't
that good yeah so this is uh
so the ultimate
title for this is the milfisa guy yeah
because you like your mum with her two
hit multi-target attacks english title
that is one big figure that's a thick
mama right god damn so
goddamn
where are we going to put that that's
actually really nice this is a really
nice figure we can show bunny girl
figures right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
of course yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
yeah
yeah bless pleasure sensei
oh thank you those those are some high
heels look at that
jesus how do i put this in
okay there we go honestly honestly i'm
happy with this figure so i got this
premise and it's a goal and she's going
huge i would like to take it huh i would
like to have one what what do you think
connor that's very good as the milf map
much better than whatever the [ __ ] this
is
this isn't even a masterpiece yeah so so
joey so joey this one's still got a
paper on it take it off the queen
the queen
okay so joey yeah um when you were
asking for incest anime yeah you could
have also got this one
oh yeah because yeah because she does
does she does do weird stuff with a song
yeah she does what yeah she does
yeah yeah so she gets in like a slime
bar with them son the premise of this
show the premise of the show is a son
gets easy-kite with his mom and this
this ain't erimanga sensei oh they're
not related by blood no they're fully
related by blood and she came out of her
yeah like he came out he he got birthed
from her vagina um he came out of the
womb and everything uh she raised him
and uh she uh she turned him into a
degenerate apparently
and there are some very very like i'll
drink to that there are some
very uh
sexy scenes on that what happens we're
talking about episode two i'm talking
about episode two episode two
um so in episode two i think let's just
say that's the episode that made me drop
the show yeah in episode two i believe
they fight a slime monster right and
this slime monster
uh has acid or slime which corrodes
everything except the body the body yeah
so it goes like it melts the it melts
the clothes off yeah
yeah yeah and uh guess guess who gets
that slime all over her body and uh
guess who
is on her body when the slime
goes on her body yes it is her son um
yep and the and the sun is this slime
where does that go and uh and
i don't actually remember the scene i
don't i believe it just go gets rid of
her clothes yeah something like that he
has like anti-slime clothes yeah
[ __ ] like that i don't know but uh
plenty of slime yeah i [ __ ] hope not
yeah
but uh yeah that was the one like
episode that made me drop this show
otherwise uh
amazing artwork yeah
one of my favorite artists oh she has
amazing artwork yeah oh very nice
they they probably got like the uh the
fishnets for that didn't yeah
i
damn boy
all right well that's a figure yeah i
thought you would like this one i do
yeah but now you've told me about that
slime it's a bit no no no you're not
really interested you're talking about
the slime i'm more excited clearly heart
is already taken by someone